[Music]
chuck i think it's about time
we talked about heat waves
uh well yeah i mean
actually wasn't that a disco group in
the 70s it was heatwave was the name of
a group yes yes
uh
they did the soundtrack to
to
what's that movie to car wash
i think their song is i want to get next
to you no that's rolls royce oh rose
royce oh damn yes
yes yeah
don't out 1970s me how you do that how
you do that oh i like
my believe it or not my daughter listens
to that music
anyhow yeah so i just thought we'd talk
about heat waves and i have other than
being familiar with the group that i
didn't properly identify from the 70s i
have no expertise in this but
we are in new york city and right up the
block from the american museum of
natural history is the goddard institute
for space studies
one one of 10 nasa centers scattered
across the country
and
we have the director of the goddard
institute for space studies
the man about town himself
gavin schmidt gavin welcome back to star
talk
hi neil how are you yeah nice to be back
excellent excellent and what many people
don't know is what that nasa center
specializes in just give me like the one
sentence sort of specialty case for it
uh time it uh climate change climate
feedbacks current responses climate
observations climate impacts the whole
of all planets
um well mostly this planet but also uh
exoplanets and also the climate of mars
the climate of venus back you know three
billion years ago uh we've been working
on all of those things well i'm glad we
made it on your list gavin
that earth is on yes
happy to see that earth is in in the
running there
yeah what people don't think that nasa
really cares about earth but actually
you know we spend more than two billion
dollars a year looking at the earth and
trying to understand what's going on and
so we actually are one of the lead
agencies uh around the world trying to
work out what is happening and why oh
and by the way
and gavin you don't have to comment on
this but
during one of my tours of duty in
washington there was there were forces
operating to prevent nasa from studying
earth saying nasa should just worry
about space and i had i was on a
commission to to to deal with this and i
said
you can't claim to understand earth
unless we know how it fits in the
context of other planets and in the
space environment and so
i think i won that fight uh because
gavin still has a job
thinking about it
with nasa that's i mean you were
eloquent in your uh in your defense
however uh it's a much simpler answer
i'm not sure if you know this but earth
is in space yes earth is in space
completely in space but that was an
early push
to remove the government from its
efforts to aid and abet the data that
was discovering climate change and who
did it exxon earth
so let's let's get back to this right so
gavin
what is a heat wave just i mean i think
we know uh heat well in new york city a
heat wave is some number of days where
the high goes above 90. right we're on
fahrenheit world here
and of course i lived in texas for a
while and
every day that's every day right so heat
wave was like over something else so
heatwave seems to be very locally
defined and does that have any meaning
to you as a climate professional
yeah so it's an interesting thing so
a lot of why we care about heat waves um
is not because of the absolute
temperature but because of the
the difference from what we're prepared
for right and and actually that that
fits in with the whole you know why do
we care about climate change right you
know it's the difference from what we
expect and so heat waves in phoenix are
going to be different from heat waves in
new york which are going to be different
than heat waves in london or in paris or
in moscow right because phoenix has been
astronomically determined to be three
quarters of a mile from the surface of
the sun
okay that makes sense
yes that was science that was that
science discovered that yes and so uh
you know people in phoenix are learning
to become nocturnal and uh we haven't
quite reached that point at uh
in new york but uh you know it's
we didn't used to have that many 90-plus
days and we're having more and more
um and so when we have uh you know a
whole big long string of these things we
can we can keep track of that and uh
that's a uh
an indication um of of extreme uh
of an extreme event associated with heat
um at the uh kind of mid-july we had um
some some very dramatic uh heat events
in europe um in the uk
and you know so the uk was still cooler
than spain but spain was really really
very hard and uh and the uk uh you know
got up to about 105 degrees fahrenheit
um which was totally unprecedented for
them yeah and you're and you're talking
about a situation there where almost
nobody has air conditioning you know
there's no air conditioning in the
subway there's no air conditioning um in
in most homes um and so
of course there they call the subway the
tube just to be clear
the subway is the walkway under a street
to get to the other side just again i
was translating for you oh thank you
thank you okay there i'm translating
back and i shouldn't be by the way
neither one of those places have air
conditioning though that's the point
that's that that was the point that was
the point yeah allow me to remind you
people if they don't already know
that the british isles
sits farther north than the northernmost
point of maine
so if you're crack if you're raking in
105 degree fahrenheit temperatures oh my
gosh yeah it's pretty clear how nobody's
prepared for that so like you said it's
it's a difference between what you're
used to and what nature hands you and
that could wreak havoc on your
i mean they had situations where they
had to stop flights out of some airports
because the ramp the runway was melting
they couldn't they couldn't run the
trains because the rails were buckling
uh you know
like when when you when you exceed
the design specifications uh for
anything you build
you get into trouble
so the lane down the track say um
you know
you we should do this to 110 degrees why
what where how what's good how's that
going to happen why it's never happened
before why would it happen again yeah
so
so that this is this is this is the
issue you know we're seeing
more of these heat waves they're
becoming more intense and that's because
of of climate change you know we we have
warmed up the planet uh by
about two degrees fahrenheit in the last
uh century or so but that is juicing
these extremes and so the number of
times you're exceeding 90 degrees
fahrenheit 100 degrees fahrenheit is
going up uh not not just like a little
bit but it's going up four or five seven
times ten times uh more than it was
before and in addition in addition to
that what what's also seemed to be
happening and i don't know if there's a
science behind this gavin but these
weather systems
seem to sit
they don't you know like so we used to
see some extreme heat
events but they would pass over now they
seem to park and stay like oh you know
what i'm a chill this is nice i like
this here and they don't go anywhere so
what is is there a science behind that
or or is that just is that
is that anecdotal
plus we have to change the word if they
sit if they're 105 degree hot spot they
can't say i'm chilling here
yeah
yeah so gavin yeah what's up with that
right so uh so so what's associated with
the with these extreme heaters is is a
wave event in in the uh in the
atmosphere in the jet stream um and and
you can see this on the weather maps
right you know you can see this this
wave kind of coming across you know each
each lobe of the wave is a couple of
thousand miles uh across and uh and
there are some patterns that happen uh
particularly when you have five of these
waves going around the world and uh and
it turns out that that's that's a
pattern that that uh
it kind of resonates a little bit and so
uh it wants to move this way the jet
stream is pushing it this way and so the
wave looks like it becomes a standing
wave right so you've got it wants to go
this way but the jet stream is pushing
it this way and so it kind of like
for people who listen only in audio you
use the word this going to your left and
to your right so could you choose a
different word
as you're doing the disco wave with your
arms okay
i i totally can't so so um imagine
imagine a a wavy sinuous like thing uh
moving uh from
kind of europe towards the to towards
the us uh meanwhile the jet stream is
pushing the other way and so when the
wave and the stream intersect uh you can
get some times when they don't appear to
move very much it's like you're you're
you have a a standing wave um that can
um
just keep things in place uh for longer
than you might imagine and uh some
people call this a blocking pattern um
and uh we and we've been looking at
these kinds of events for many many
decades um and there's some indication
that they may be
kind of changing a little bit um uh with
with climate change but that i think i
would say that that's very much uh at
the cutting edge of what we understand
and what we don't have okay so so gavin
you got london here and i know a lot of
people live in london and it is europe
and everything but
you know africa is five times the size
of europe so a few cities in europe get
a high temperature earth is way bigger
than europe
why why do why does anyone give a rat's
ass about no i mean i don't mean to make
light of it but what i want to say is
why make global proclamations about
what's happening in a couple of places
in europe just because they're
complaining louder because the queen is
there and she's very fragile when it
comes to high heat okay thank you for
that i think she probably has air
conditioning
[Laughter]
and if not if not there are people
waving a
big palm fronds
palm leaves are waved at her yes
okay oh yeah i can i couldn't speak to
that um
but you know you make it you raise it
you raise a good point you know why why
do we pay attention to uh to some events
and and not others well one of the
reasons is that in the mid-latitudes so
kind of you know yeah
north of the mediterranean north of the
mexican border
we see a lot more summer variability
right we see we see a lot more of these
waves coming by uh that can move you
into colder or warmer conditions
and
uh in the tropics uh you don't get that
so much um uh tropical climate is much
more stable
um you know the temperatures uh don't
vary that much you get a wet and a dry
season which uh uh which makes a
difference depending
on what side of the equator you're on um
but the temperatures during the
summer time and not that that really
makes that much difference uh i are
pretty stable
and so uh you don't get these kinds of
extreme events uh happening uh you you
see them um you know in india uh we've
seen we've seen some tremendous uh heat
waves in india and pakistan uh in in
the rest of uh south asia um uh and in
uh china as well and in australia like
going the going the other way in south
africa and the heatwaves feed these
these fires that we've all been hearing
about right so he he leads to a lot of
different things right so you first of
all you dry out right so your soil
moisture evaporates right so so
everything gets drier um
as things get drier they become more
flammable um and so we see uh situations
where you know grass that would normally
never burn suddenly is flammable um and
we're seeing uh lots of cases where you
know seemingly you know inadvertent
sparks uh or or accidents and now uh
instead of just like dying out and being
put out uh are leading to large
configurations and so you know uh london
for instance um
had after after the the day after the
maximum heat had its um had its biggest
fire day since since the second world
war
uh um and and those are obviously two
different causes um yes i would i would
hope so yes uh but uh you know they they
had they had uh large-scale fires like
taking out you know city blocks
uh that uh that people had just never
seen before
so so
if
try to tr
help me out here because i'm sure people
are thinking this you're telling me
we've increased two degrees in the last
century or so basically the era of the
modern industrial revolution and yet
london is not two degrees warmer
than its average it's way higher than
its average so
how does two degrees
warmer on earth translate into 10 20 30
degrees higher than average
uh temperatures anywhere on earth okay
so
let's break that down a little bit so
the two degrees that people talk about
that i just mentioned uh is the global
average change right um uh but you have
to remember that the globe is not
warming evenly it's warming more on land
than the ocean it's warming more in the
north than in the south and it's warming
most of all in places like the arctic
uh so the changes uh in in new york or
in london or in paris uh are more than
the two degrees fahrenheit that we're
talking about in the global mean so so
they're about you know maybe maybe one
and a half two times that so so maybe
four degrees fahrenheit five degrees
fahrenheit okay so maybe so so maybe you
should change the messaging it's not
what the average over the whole world is
if that it because if it's a huge range
in the manifestation
if that average is an average over a
wide range of data a wide range of
values then why not give the average
increase at this latitude we're at the
same latitude as as madrid or
right through we're sorry we new york
city
there and and what what the change is at
maine and and in the arctic why don't i
give those numbers we so we do right so
the arctic is no you don't i've not
heard used to give that okay yeah yeah
oh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna give it to
you
the average the average change in the
arctic is about four times the global me
now hampton
have you heard anybody say that chuck no
i want to tell you here's the problem
gavin so as a scientist when you look at
uh incremental change you're able to
understand that people are not if you
tell me it's two degrees warmer in this
room than it is in the other room that
means nothing to me it means you don't
give a rat's ass i don't care what you
need you're not adjusting the thermostat
for that i'm not what you guys need
is an id is a is a scale that registers
in the human psyche so so in one part of
the world it's oh my god hot okay
and if we keep going if we keep going it
gets to god damn right
okay
well let me let me bring out this scale
that i i prepared earlier he's trying to
stop you there chuck because there's no
there's no coming back from that
so you're absolutely right you know
we're talking about numbers that really
don't mean very much to people in their
everyday lives and so
quite frankly i don't like talking about
these numbers i don't like talking about
two degrees 1.5 degrees to like four
degrees um they they are very hard to
conceptualize because people uh people's
experience of temperature in their local
environments uh during a day over a
season uh is very different to the
planet's experience of temperature uh
and so one of the things that uh that i
like to uh to bring up um is uh what
what what does what what kind of
temperatures is the planet scene
uh over over its history um and one
great example is about twenty thousand
years ago we were in the middle of uh
the the ice age
and uh you know where uh where you guys
are sitting now uh was was under it was
underneath um
was underneath the hundreds of meters of
ice the the glaciers extended from the
arctic ocean uh to prospect park in
brooklyn uh they covered almost all of
uh of north america there's something
similar uh happening in uh in the uk
there was another by the way gavin as a
as a kid i remember
we took a tour of central park right in
the middle of manhattan and there were
rock escarpments that were identified as
having glacial uh uh scarring creation
yes striations right and i'm a kid right
glacier what's a glacier doing here what
what glacier
it was there yeah no i remember the the
the mental
adjustments i had to make to embrace
what was going on so so
the ice age was a was a radically
different climate right so you know
where we have forests and trees and it
was it was ice um and then for hundreds
of miles further south it was tundra uh
the fauna is different the ecosphere is
different uh sea level is different and
do you know what the global temperature
change was
between then and now between between
then and secondary industries right okay
emma how much
it was about eight or nine degrees
fahrenheit
okay
right
so that's helpful
i can use that i can use that yeah so
what so what i like to do is let's call
that an ice age unit right so that's
that's that's a big change for the
planet right right right and if you go
from where we were to the ice age that's
one ice age unit um and now what we've
done
since the beginning of the industrial
revolution is we've gone up
about a quarter to a fifth of an ice age
unit and where we might be heading
could be a whole ice age unit in the
other direction
right right right and so we think oh
these are small numbers but they're not
small to them the planet
notices these things the planet uh feels
these changes in the ecosystems in the
ice uh in the temperature and in the
extremes okay this is very helpful
that's where we come back to what's
happening now
we're seeing the impacts of these things
in the extremes because
if you couldn't if you can imagine uh
you know a bell curve right
um and we're moving the middle of that
bell curve a little bit to to
to the warmer conditions by you know a
couple of degrees but the things that
are changing the most
are out of the ends are out at the very
warmest temperatures or the very coldest
temperatures so if you're in the middle
of the belka if you don't notice it but
on the extremes oh my gosh it's the
extreme right right okay and and it's
the extremes that make the impact right
nobody cares if a mediocre day is two
degrees four degrees five degrees warmer
than a previous mediocre day but when
you get to 100 degrees plus
every additional
degree
makes a difference it makes a difference
uh to how much the the
the rails are going to buckle it makes a
difference to how much the airport is
going to melt it makes a difference how
much
we can't land because the airport melted
that's great so you know i know we got
to wrap up but i got to ask you this uh
gavin because so the things that you're
talking about are infrastructure and
that's a big deal because that costs
people a lot of money costs governments
a lot of money and and
and resources
but
it still doesn't affect people's psyche
because they look at it like well that's
why i pay taxes and that's what the
government is for so what i want what i
want to know is
when does it get to a place where we see
we exact a personal cost like
where your health is really in danger
like there is a a heat limit when you
look at humidity versus temperature that
human beings cannot exist
uh yeah no there is i mean for for
places like the uk were quite a ways
from that places like dubai and india
we're a little bit closer uh and and in
fact we're going to see
places kind of hitting those limits
mostly in the tropics not in the not in
these kind of heat wave situations in
the mid latitudes
uh mainly because the humidity is is
higher in the tropics um but we're but
we we already feel
the impact the health impacts of of heat
every time there's an event like this in
the uk they're anticipating uh perhaps a
thousand uh excess deaths because of the
uh the two day heat wave or we see it um
in uh
when we have uh heat waves in in the u.s
um there's a big increase in in
mortality uh you know most unfortunately
mostly uh elderly uh people
um good life
it's it's
all for small children being being
trapped in cars right
yeah right i read i read a great uh
article just yesterday believe it or not
people
heat-related events
kill more people in the united states
than any other
um weather event you take all the other
weather events and heat is the one that
does it
okay all right yeah yes well guys we
gotta we gotta see those impacts we got
to land this plane on our melting
airport
so
so
gavin thanks for on short notice coming
in to do this because we we've just been
seeing these reports of heat waves all
around the world and we wanted to get
some climate change perspective on it
which you duly provided so i know you're
on holiday right now thanks for dialing
into this and it's always good to have
you in arms reach oh you feel privileged
that you're there for us chuck i know
you're a climate uh
bit time enthusiastic and and uh
fundraisers that you do
uh and you host and it's a great to know
that you're you're you're walking the
walk not just talking the talk
absolutely all right uh i'm neil degrass
tyson this has been a heatwave explainer
on star talk keep looking up
[Music]